What should the proposal be?
And specifically
I agree with you on the issue of violence.
but animal abuse,
why
society should be talked about
Do I get so many problems?
This one as you well point out Arturo
and put in the first place
with others other than animal abuse,
I think everything is a chain of problems,
not everything comes together,
no then
to talk about a solution,
for it is obviously education,
isn't it education?
In the first instance,
it's my opinion,
education of children,
care
a to this problem,
not that they have
not in schools,
that in fact
some talks have been held
what they are going to put in
eh subjects in education schools
environmental and animal respect education,
I think it would be a good way to get started.
And if you ask me as a rescuer,
eh?
that day by day I am living this
and that we cannot cope with it,
so we can't cope
The same applies to a public prosecutor's office dedicated 100% to animal abuse?
No,
because a single prosecution does not give itself
for all that there is not this then
I think it could also be a great idea,
not a public prosecutor's office that is dedicated to animal abuse